había corridas gritos fuego lanzas por
todos lados estaban invadiendo la ciudad
pero a él a él parecía que no le
importaba
él seguía sentado dibujando en la arena
figuras matemáticas hasta que un soldado
romano lo amenazó con su espada y lo
quiso tomar prisionero
el anciano tranquilo
levantó la mirada lo miró a los ojos y
le dijo que primero iba a terminar su
demostración luego bajó la mirada y
siguió dibujando en la arena
cuando los romanos invadieron sicilia
siracusa parecía un blanco fácil sin
embargo le llevó más de dos años
conquistarla
fue la primera batalla en la que la
tecnología hizo la diferencia se
utilizaron catapultas grandes grúas que
daban vuelta a los barcos por el aire y
muchas otras innovaciones
cuenta plutarco que los romanos estaban
tan aterrados que veían una soga o una
polea y salían corriendo
todos esos inventos eran obra de un
único hombre
quién es ese gigante que con sus
inventos hacía temblar al ejército
romano
nada más y nada menos que arquímedes el
matemático más importante de toda la
antigüedad
finalmente los romanos conquistaron la
ciudad al soldado obviamente le molestó
la actitud de arquímedes y lo atravesó
con su espada
un terrible error que tuvo que pagar muy
caro porque su general marcó claudio
marcelo admiraba profundamente
arquímedes
de hecho marcó claudio pudiendo llevarse
todos los tesoros de la ciudad eligió
uno solo que cabía en cualquier bolso
un aparato que había hecho alquileres
si 0 nos cuenta que en una especie de
planetario portátil que mostraba la
posición del sol de la luna de las
estrellas y que cuando lo hizo funcionar
predijo eclipses
cómo habrá sido ese planetario portátil
si se dice que jamás pensó que un ser
humano podría ser tan genial para hacer
algo así
el general romano lo prefirió antes que
a cualquier otro tesoro
como habrá sido se imaginan lo que sería
tenerlo en las manos
y poder estudiarlo poder investigarlo
poder tocarlo
sin embargo como tantas maravillas de la
antigüedad se había perdido para siempre
o al menos eso parecía porque en 1900 se
encontró un barco hundido en el fondo
del mediterráneo cerca de la isla de
anticitera lleno de tesoros de la época
de los griegos impresionantes estatuas
joyas monedas y algo muy curioso esto
un montón de fragmentos de lo que
parecía ser una especie de reloj antiguo
lleno de engranajes
esto ya era tremendamente revolucionario
porque aparatos así aparecen recién a
fines de la edad media 1500 años después
estaríamos frente a los restos del
aparato de arquímedes
para contestar esta pregunta primero
teníamos que reconstruir el aparato
original a partir de los fragmentos y
volver a hacerlo funcionar una tarea
quijotesca que ya lleva más de un siglo
en los años 50 trabajó un norteamericano
solá price y luego dos británicos
michael wright a partir de los 90 y toni
freeze y su equipo que arrancó en el
2000 justamente el equipo de freeze sacó
una radio una tomografía de muchísima
resolución que nos permiten ver el
interior de los fragmentos miren ustedes
empezamos desde afuera y de a poco vamos
entrando en el fragmento esto es
importantísimo porque por supuesto en
emociona nos permiten romper el
mecanismo para ver lo que hay en su
interior bien y ven cómo están esos
dientes miren cómo se han conservado
2000 años debajo del agua
ahora están publicitando las primeras
tablets que son sumergibles esto es
sumergible 2000 años debajo del agua
miren cómo está es una locura
según lo que hemos podido reconstruir
hasta ahora
el mecanismo estaba protegido por una
caja de madera y tenía una tapa delante
y una tapa atrás en la parte de adelante
tenía dos escalas concéntricas una
estaba dividida en los doce signos del
zodíaco y la otra en los 365 días del
año
sobre esas escalas gira una aguja que
muestra al mismo tiempo la posición del
sol en el cielo y el día del año
pero sobre esas escalas también gira
otra aguja que muestra la posición de la
luna en el cielo
y el error
de esa aguja según los valores actuales
es del 0,00
dos días por vuelta pero eso no es todo
la aguja de la luna en su recorrido no
va a una velocidad constante sino que a
veces acelera y a veces desacelera
estos tipos habían logrado que la aguja
de la luna tampoco fuera una velocidad
constante sino que de hecho acelerará
cuando la luna va más rápido y
desacelerar cuando va más despacio
y como si esto fuera poco además la
aguja de la luna tenía una pelotita
mitad pintada de negro y está pintada de
blanco que giraba mostrando las fases de
la luna
si me preguntan a mí solamente
arquímedes puede haber hecho algo así
en la parte de atrás tenemos dos grandes
relojes en forma de espiral
el de abajo es un predictor de eclipses
se acuerdan que si será un dijo que el
de arquímedes predecía eclipses
los eclipses se repiten cada 223 meses
para cada uno hay una celda la mayoría
están vacías pero cuando hay un eclipse
la celda informa si será solar o lunar
si se lo podrá observar o no e incluso a
qué hora sucederá
el de arriba tiene dos pequeños relojes
en su interior
uno de esos da una vuelta cada cuatro
años y le informaba al usuario cuando
sucederían las olimpíadas
en la espiral grande es un calendario
lunisolar que reparte doscientos treinta
y cinco meses en diecinueve años es un
calendario tremendamente preciso al
nuestro tenemos que agregarle un día
cada cuatro años los años bisiestos para
que no se desajusta
a este hay que sacarle un día cada 76
años
claro uno podría decir quién se va a
acordar de sacar un día cada siete
décadas y pico para eso el mecanismo
contaba con el otro relojito que daba
justamente una vuelta cada 76 años para
recordarle al usuario que tenía que
emitir un día
el calendario tiene el nombre de los
meses y esto resulta muy importante
porque cada ciudad griega tenía su
propio calendario con sus propios
nombres y se pudo determinar
que el calendario del mecanismo coincide
con el de corinto o alguna de sus
colonias
saben ustedes qué ciudad fue colonia de
corinto durante mucho tiempo siracusa la
ciudad de arquímedes
es entonces el aparato de arquímedes
la realidad es que el aparato de
arquímedes y el de anticitera ejercen el
mismo tipo de hechizo frente a todos los
que entran en contacto con ellos
sabemos que el general romano quedó
poseído cuando lo vio y lo prefirió
antes que a cualquier otro tesoro
algo parecido a lo que le pasó a gollum
el del señor de los anillos'
con el anillo defrauda
si serán también quedó maravillado
cuando lo vio funcionar y se volvió
fanático de arkin es el mecanismo de
arquímedes ejercía ese tipo de encanto
pero uno muy parecido ejerce el de
anticitera solá price una vez que
conoció los fragmentos trabajó con ellos
hasta su muerte a michael wright casi lo
echan del trabajo por investigar este
aparato
toni freeze hipotecó su futuro económico
para financiar la investigación
yo mismo debo confesar que también caí
bajo su encanto y hace ya cinco años que
trabajó ininterrumpidamente en el
mecanismo
me acuerdo qué
la primera vez que vi los fragmentos en
el museo en atenas
me quedé como hipnotizada no no podía
dejar de mirarlos debo haber pasado hay
varias horas
mirando los fragmentos desde todos los
ángulos posibles
hasta que la gente de seguridad del
museo se puso nerviosa pensando que me
lo quería robar y la verdad ganas no me
faltaban
pero no es solo el encanto que produce
lo que nos hace sospechar que es el
mismo aparato hay varios signos que
apuntan a arquímedes
el calendario podría ser el de siracusa
la descripción de cicerón coincide mucho
con lo que hemos podido reconstruir el
proyector de eclipses también apunta a
arquímedes sin embargo todavía falta una
prueba muy importante
sin eso no tenemos nada la fecha de
construcción del mecanismo
para atarlo se ha intentado estudiar la
forma de las letras de las inscripciones
pero el margen de error es muy grande es
mayor a 100 años
el carbono 14 nos sirve porque se aplica
materia orgánica y los engranajes son de
bronce pero hay otra posibilidad en el
predictor de eclipses nosotros tenemos
las horas y los días en los que
sucederán eclipses si encontrábamos la
serie de eclipses reales que mejor
calzan con esos datos sabríamos en qué
época se construyó
esta propuesta que en teoría es viable
en la práctica nunca funcionó porque hay
un montón de datos del proyector de
eclipses que no terminamos de entender
bien uno especialmente molesto es que
mientras predice todos los eclipses
lunares predice solamente algunos
eclipses solares por alguna razón el que
hizo el aparato decidió omitir algunos
eclipses solares para colmo esos
eclipses olvidados parecen no seguir
ninguna lógica parecen excluidos al azar
son los eclipses que ustedes ven en rojo
un día después de trabajar ya la tarde
con las tomografías simplemente se me
ocurrió trasladar los eclipses de la
espiral de abajo a la espiral de arriba
a ver cómo se acomodaban no tenía
ninguna razón para hacerlo pero
simplemente lo hice y miren lo que pasó
parecía mágico de pronto todos los
eclipses se organizaron formando rayos y
lo que es más importante
esos eclipses emitidos estos eclipses
olvidados estaban formando dos rayos muy
bien definidos había encontrado la
lógica de la exclusión de estos eclipses
se lo comunique a mi colega de
investigación james evans y él enseguida
entendió de qué se trataba eso nos daba
muchísima información extra
sobre el predictor de eclipses tal vez
ahora sí
podíamos encontrar la fecha de
construcción
nos pusimos inmediatamente a trabajar
fueron años y años de quemarnos la
cabeza
de seguir una estrategia que después no
conducía a ningún lado de entusiasmarnos
con un resultado para después darnos
cuenta y que habíamos cometido algún
error para bote en los cálculos
hasta que un día
en febrero de un domingo de febrero del
año pasado
estaba yo en la casa de mi colega en
eeuu
nos dimos cuenta que no había forma de
avanzar
de que incluso utilizando todos los
datos disponibles teníamos demasiadas
fechas posibles
recuerdo que esa noche nos despedimos
con la sensación amarga de que el
proyecto que ya llevaba más de tres años
había fracasado
yo no lo podía creer
frente a él disimuló mantuve la
compostura pero cuando bajé las
escaleras se dormían en el sótano en su
casa
está lleno de libros de historia y la
astronomía es espectacular cuando bajé
las escaleras y me senté en la cama no
podía crear
no podía ser el duelo tantos años
trabajando y no habíamos llegado a nada
me puse a repasar me puse a hacer las
cuentas de nuevo me puse a revisar todo
hasta que de pronto
se me ocurrió considerar un dato de la
anomalía lunar que no habíamos tenido en
cuenta y ese dato resultó tremendamente
poderoso
y si las cuentas y eliminó a todos los
candidatos excepto uno
esa noche encontramos el resultado
pensar que estuvimos a punto de
abandonar que estábamos ahí nomás de la
solución
hoy
después de más de un año y medio de
revisar cuidadosamente todos los
cálculos y de chequear absolutamente
todos los datos les puedo anunciar
oficialmente que el primer eclipse del
mecanismo sucedió el 25 de junio del año
de 205 antes de cristo- a las 15 y 35
hora local de atenas eso
eso quiere decir
que el calendario habría empezado en
septiembre o agosto del año 216 cuando
todavía arquímedes nuestro queridísimo
arquímedes estaba bien vivito y coleando
si señoras y señores este mecanismo
podría haber sido hecho por el mismo
arquímedes
me imagino que
a la tarde cuando lleguen a sus casas se
van a poner a buscar información por
internet sobre el mecanismo si alguno no
lo está haciendo ahora ya escondidas en
su celular
pueden hacerlo hay muchísimas
pero si de pronto se dan cuenta de que
hace ya 10 horas que están frente a la
computadora de que se olvidaron de
almorzar o de cenar o que faltaron al
trabajo
cuidado
tal vez ya sea demasiado tarde y habrán
caído como muchos de nosotros
poseídos por su encanto